[Musique]
l'héritière du puissant et très convoité
duché d'aquitaine
aliénor est le plus beau parti d'europe
reine de france puis d'angleterre mère
de trois rois fans de pouvoir et
d'autorité dans un monde chevalier
imprégné par l'idéal des croisades
l'influencent d'aliénor d'aquitaine
traverse le xiième siècle elle a servi
les intérêts de l'angleterre lors de son
deuxième mariage mais elle a joué un
rôle considérable dans l'ain
l'édification du royaume de france
auparavant richard devise chroniqueurs
de l'époque décrit une femme
incomparable belle mais pudique
puissante et douce humble et plein
d'esprit des qualités ajoutent ils que
l'on retrouve rarement chez une femme
alors aliénor d'aquitaine on le sait on
a écrit des tas de livres même des
romans sur aliénor d'aquitaine est une
femme exquise très belle ravissante mais
ambitieuse intelligente cupide avides
sensuelle
enfin elle a tout pour plaire répudié
par le roi de france louis 7
aliénor renverse l'équilibré des
pouvoirs elle est avec henri ii
d'angleterre à l'origine d'une dynastie
légendaire celle des plantagenêts que le
chroniqueur giraud de bari qualifie de
dynasty issus du diable tête politique
aliénor rennes sur un véritable empire
qui s'étend des îles britanniques aux
pyrénées et donne naissance au célèbre
richard coeur de lion et jean sans terre
qui vont nourrir pour des siècles
l'imaginaire populaire
la littérature et l'histoire se sont
emparés de son destin tourmenté
contribuant à bâtir à outrance sa
légende noire
l'historien edmond rené la bande voit en
elle une véritable louve avide de
pouvoir
celle dont le coeur fille si souvent
troublées dont l'ambition souleva temps
d'orage dans les brumes du moyen âge
pièce maîtresse de la famille
plantagenêt dont elle a fait l'ascension
et emporté le déclin aliénor est
l'incarnation d'une époque et demeure
une femme exceptionnelle qui continue
aujourd'hui encore à alimenter bien des
fantasmes
le partage de l'empiré de charlemagne en
843 donne peu à peu d'essence au royaume
de france 12e siècle ce royaume se
compose d'une multitude de fiefs du che
est content et gouvernés par des
seigneurs faso du rois capétiens qui ne
possède plus qu'un domaine réduit depuis
lequel il exerce l'autorité centrale
la féodalité système politique qui régit
la société au moyen âge ce qu'on soit
sous la forme d'une pyramide où chaque
niveau obéit à un seigneur plus
puissants faisant remonter la réalité du
pouvoir
jusqu'au roi à la mort du dernier
empereur carolingien charles iii de gros
en 1888 le royaume d'aquitaine devient
un duché gouverné par guillaume le pieux
chef de la maison des contes d'auvergne
et premier duc de l'histoire après la
mort de guillaume le pieux et de ses
deux fils sans descendance masculine une
farouche guerre de succession en flammes
l'aquitaine les comptes de poitiers
reprennent alors la couronne ducale
qu'ils transmettent à leur fils aîné qui
portent tous le nom de guillaume entre
995 et 1030 guillaume 5 legrand
gouvernants véritable souverain
l'aquitaine qui s'étend du poitou à
l'auvergne manifestants des velléités
d'indépendance
il fait de poitiers la capitale du duché
et favorise la culture
mais très vite il se heurte aux
ambitions de ces petits seigneurs
vassaux qui entendent élargir leurs
prérogatives
dès le 11e siècle le duché se
métamorphosent on défriche les forêts on
assèche les marécages de nouveaux
villages et châteaux sortent de terre
l'église entreprend des constructions
monumentales de style roman pour chanter
la gloire de dieu sous la gouvernance de
guillaume 9 le troubadour 2086 à 11 126
mécène avant l'heure et poète lui-même
l'avis de course enrichi d'une poésie
profane en langue vernaculaire qui fait
l'apologie de l'amour courtois sa petite
fille aliénor grandi au milieu des
jongleurs et des hommes de lettres elle
est la fille aînée de guillaume 10
d'aquitaine est d'allier nord de
châtellerault
le première tragédie marque l'enfance
d'aliénor elle perd sa mère en 1130 sept
ans plus tard avant d'effectuer un
pèlerinage à saint jacques de
compostelle
guillaume 10 qui n'a pas de fils fait
jurer à tous ses vassaux fidélité à
aliénor sage précaution
guillaume lui va avoir l'idée saugrenue
de mourir en partant pèlerinage à saint
jacques de compostelle un vendredi saint
qui plus est à 38 ans il va laisser il
va laisser le duché d'aquitaine à la
petite aliénor qu'il aimait tant parce
qu'il n'ya pas de loi salique en
aquitaine là ça n'est pas comme chez les
francs saliens où c'est l'homme qui rit
elle hérite le duché d'aquitaine
guillaume vient de faire de sa fille la
plus riche héritière d'europe attirant
la convoitise du rois capétiens
louis 6 legros ali au nord possède une
personnalité très forte elle a sans
doute à peine 15 ans quand elle succède
à son père à la tête du duché
d'aquitaine qui représente presque le
quart de la france c'est dire toute
l'importance politique et stratégique
que va avoir son futur mariage
le roi des francs louis 6 le gros est
assez clairvoyant il passe son règne à
chevaucher l'épée à la main
mais il a aussi l'ambition de consolider
son pouvoir
et de fédérer ses vassaux autour de lui
contre les agressions extérieures
swiss s'appuie sur un conseiller prudent
et habile la baie de saint denis suger
et parvient en 1124 à résister à une
coalition anglo germanique pour la
première fois depuis l'avènement de la
dynastie capétienne tous les vassaux se
mobilisent pour défendre le pouvoir de
leurs droits le duc de bourgogne
le comte de champagne le comte de
flandre comte d'anjou le duc de bretagne
et le duc d'aquitaine
répondant à l'appel du capétiens
resserrant les liens féodaux à la fin de
son règne sur les conseils avisés de
l'abbé suger louis 6 cell le destin de
son royaume ans marion son fils aîné
louis à aliénor le 25 juillet 1137 dans
le cadre de ce mariage éminemment
politique s'opère alors un choc des
cultures à l'est nord quitte son pays
pour un autre à paris on ne parle pas la
même langue la france du nord parle la
langue d'oil centralisé autour de saint
denis et de reims s'y déploie une
culture imprégnée de religiosité et
d'austérité
contrastant avec une france du sud
libéral et enthousiaste où on s'exprime
en languedoc louis peut espérer rattaché
l'aquitaine aux maigres domaine royal
soit tout le sud ouest de la france
mais il ya encore des contradictions a
levé et bien des passions à canaliser
louis 6 legros meurt le 1er août
1137 l'époux d'aliénor est propulsé roi
de france sous le nom de luis est ce
dernier n'était pas destiné à régner la
mort de son frère aîné six ans
auparavant le sortait du cloître notre
dame où ils étaient élevés afin de lui
apprendre à gouverner il en gardera le
surnom de luis est le pieux sont deux
personnalités totalement différente
le syndicat thivel et lesperon elle est
courageuse lui est un peu mou hésitant
un peu bigot die on surnomme luiz est le
pieux aliénor et non seulement belle
mais elle est aussi brillant et vive
d'esprit sa forte personnalité influence
louis 7 et les deux époux apparaissent
dans un premier temps comme des alliés à
la tête du royaume
louis m aliénor d'une façon immodéré ses
conseillers la ixe au clair voit déjà
dans cet amour
la faiblesse d'adam pour eve au début le
couple royal s'entend parfaitement et
aliénor donne son avis concernant la
politique d'expansion du royaume car
elle aime parler politique en 1141 en
louis 7 entreprend une campagne
militaire contre le comté de toulouse
sur lequel aliénor à des droits par sa
grand-mère faire tomber le comté de
toulouse dans l'escarcelle du roi
permettrait d'ouvrir un accès à la
précieuse mer méditerranée mais le conte
et résiste alors qu'un autre conflit va
se nouer en champagne en 1141 le cousin
de luis est raoul vermandois alors âgé
d'une cinquantaine d'années s'éprend de
pétronille la jeune soeur d'aliénor qui
à tout juste 15 ans raul n'est pas libre
et l'oncle de sa femme et le comte de
champagne petroni la petite soeur
d'aliénor d'aquitaine et follement
amoureuse de raul de vermandois et oui
mais c'est un amour impossible puisque
raul vermandois est déjà marié à
eléonore de blois bon elle va demander
la petite pétronille avait demandé
aliénor sa grande soeur et mon mari
l'aliénor le roi de france louis 7 de
procéder à la dissolution du mariage ce
qu'ils vont faire d'ailleurs et oui mais
ça va contrarier férocement la famille
de raul de vermandois et notamment son
frère qui va prendre les armes contre le
roi de france
le couple royal soutient l'annulation de
ce mariage afin que raul époux sa bien
aimée et persiste face au refus de
l'église et du pape le conflit éclate
donc avec la champagne
il faut l'intervention du très
conservateur bernard de clairvaux en
1144 pour mettre fin à cette crise
aliénor est marié depuis sept ans elle
n'a pas eu d'enfants il semble que la
pression morale exercée par le moine
associé à l' angoisse de la reine qui
n'est pas encore maire et poussé aliénor
à faire reculer son époux sur la plupart
des causes du conflit d'appel retrouver
les relations avec la papauté reprises
aliénor met au monde une fille marie en
1145 mais pour lui le pieux l'expiation
des fautes passe par une croisade
si jérusalem n'est stratégique ni sur le
plan politique ni sur le plan économique
depuis les années 1500 tu les invasions
turc sèment l'anarchie et ruine les
pèlerinages en palestine à partir de
1078 les turcs refusent de laisser libre
accès à la ville sainte 1078 que cela
style est bien là ce sont les turcs qui
envahissent jérusalem l'islam et à
jérusalem
et c'est le coup d'envoi des croisades
lors du concile de clermont le 27
novembre 1095 le pape urbain 2 lance un
appel à la croisade
le message est clair délivré jerusalem
la promesse du salut éternel aliments
alors la quête de tous ceux qui se
disent chevalier ce sont les plus
modestes qui partent les premiers c'est
la croisade des pauvres gens laboureurs
et artisans les chevaliers eux
respectent la date annoncée par le
souverain pontife
le 15 août les croisés prennent
jérusalem le 15 juillet 1099 et créer un
royaume chrétien les états latins
d'orient le 31 mars 1946 la deuxième
croisade et lancé officiellement par
bernard de clairvaux lors d'un prêche
enflammé avait ce lait louis le pieux se
croisent sans hésiter l'expédition peut
commencer
aliénor décide d'accompagner son dépôt
en croisade sans se douter un seul
instant que cette expédition va faire
basculer son destin et écrire sa légende
noire
la croisade entreprises par a'liénor et
louis va marquer un tournant dans leur
relation et dans l'histoire de france
c'est en terre sainte au cours de
l'année 1148 que se produit une série
d'incidents et le traversent la
méditerranée et lui veut marcher vers
jérusalem à tout prix or on s'arrête à
antioch où il y à là l'oncle d'aliénor
qui demande au secours parce qu'il est
cerné et ses parts par les infidèles et
qui a besoin d'un coup de main
le couple royal est accueilli par
raymond de poitiers fils de guillaume le
troubadour et jeune prince francs du
royaume d'antioche
après avoir séjourné à constantinople
une autre cour d'orient offre à aliénor
une vision plus proche de ses idéaux que
celle de paris une vision moins austère
et plus ambitieuse raymond compte sur
l'aide de louis pour regagner du terrain
face aux infidèles échaudé par des
déboires subis plus au nord louis veut
éviter l'affrontement et donne la
priorité à un pèlerinage à jérusalem
les rumeurs et les railleries commence à
aller bon train quand on évoque le temps
que passent ensemble
raymond et aliénor elle reste avec son
oncle les mauvaises langues diront même
que ça a été une grande histoire un
steak incestueuses entre l'oncle et
aliénor elle même c'est une rumeur
rien de plus sur laquelle va se
cristalliser toutes les légendes noires
d'aliénor si l'on en croit le témoignage
de jean de salisbury un proche
contemporain elle est totalement infondé
jean de salisbury écrit les
conversations assidus
il n'a interrompu du prince vraiment et
de la reine ex iter la suspicion du roi
plusieurs témoins de l'époque critique
en outre la véhémence avec laquelle
louis 7ème aliénor ce sont des êtres
passionner ses chroniqueurs disent
qu'ils aiment comme un enfant jaloux
mais les ménestrels et les écrivains ça
fait partie de l'époque des siècles
suivants ne manqueront pas de donner la
interprétation de l'événement écrivant
peut-être inventant des détails
croustillants de la légende de
l'infidèle aliénor le départ pour
jérusalem est avancée mais aliénor
refuse de suivre louis devant son
insistance le rappel des devoirs d'une
femme
aliénor demande l'annulation du mariage
pour cause de consanguinité menace
reposant effectivement sur des éléments
avérés il aurait un ancêtre commun le
roi robert le pieux mort en 1031 louis
est tentée de l'apprendre ombre mais il
y suit les conseils de ses barons et
enlève aliénor afin de l'emmener avec
lui à jérusalem le pèlerinage se déroule
comme prévu mais les tentatives de
reconquête en terre sainte et shu le
couple royal rentrer de croisade dans
deux navires différents leur route passe
par rome où semble-t-il le pape réussi à
les réconcilier pour deux ans seulement
le temps de voir naître un autre enfant
une autre fille
cette mauvaise réputation d'aliénor est
aussi à n'en pas douter due au fait
qu'elle va renverser les alliances et
faire basculer le pouvoir territorial en
faveur de l'angleterre
les chroniqueurs français vont donc un
peu se déchaîner contre elle c'est une
traîtresse en montrant un visage
diabolique
à la fin du xiiie siècle jacques mars
chez les donne une suite satirique au
fameux roman de renart intitulé renard
le nouvel on y trouve un personnage
appelé noble qui incarne le roi et qui
s'oppose à renard la personnification de
l'amanite
renard a subtilisé à noble les clés de
son château et copule avec sa femme
nommée à rouge
elle est représentée sous les traits
d'un léopard
nul besoin de traduction pour tous les
contemporains de l'auteur qui voit
aliénor dans à rouge et reconnaissent
bien sûr luiz est dans le pauvre noble
tromper entre louis 7 et aliénor la
rupture est bel et bien consommé
en partant en croisade louis 7 avait
laissé le champ libre à l'ambition de
jofra lebel comte d'anjou profitant
d'une guerre entre les prétendants au
trône d'angleterre
geoffroy qui avait déposé la petite
fille de guillaume le conquérant
mathilde l'en presse avait fait valoir
ses droits sur le duché de normandie
il y avait même investi son fils henri
plantagenêt sans l'accord de son
souverain
luis est le nom vient de son père qui
avait coutume de porter une petite
brindille de jeunes et à son chapeau
d'où le nom de plantage les
affrontements éclatent en 1151 et
bernard de clairvaux intervient de
nouveau pour négocier un accord henry
âgé de 17 ans vient à paris prêter
hommage à son roi et être confirmée ducs
de normandie du jeune homme robuste et
de belle allure porte une branche de
jeunes et à son chapeau et une nouvelle
rumeur celle de trop se met à courir
qu'aliénor de presque dix ans son aîné
n'est pas insensible à son charme
l'annulation du mariage de louer et
d'aliénor est prononcée en 1152 lors
d'une assemblée ecclésiastique à
beaugency aliénor n'a pas donné
d'héritier à la couronne de france
elle est pourtant contrainte de laisser
ses deux filles à paris sous la
protection de leur père alors au retour
des croisades bien le la situation du
ménage du couple louis 7 et aliénor
n'est pas vraiment idyllique parce que
on l'a vu elle est très contrarié par le
caractère un peu indolente son mari elle
reste en aquitaine et lui sommes tous
très bien s'il fait le bilan de cette
croisade c'est un bilan relativement
catastrophique il a perdu beaucoup
d'hommes financièrement c'est aussi
quelque chose qui lui a coûté très cher
sentiment tellement senti mentalement il
a perdu son épouse et territorialement
comme elles gardent l'aquitaine qui ne
veut pas lui donner
eh bien il n'a plus rien à gagner louis
7 vient de commettre une faute politique
dont il aurait pu mesurer certaines
conséquences
il vient de donner sans le savoir le
coup d'envoi de la première guerre de
cent ans
aliénor qui a récupéré son duché
d'aquitaine ne peut rester sans mari une
réelle menace plane sur la duchesse et
sont juteuses héritage après
l'annulation de son mariage avec lui cet
allié nord reste un très beau parti
durant le trajet entre paris et poitiers
siège de sa cour d'aquitaine la duchesse
manque de se faire enlever à deux
reprises par le comte de blois thibault
5 puis par le duc de normandie en
sécurité dans son fief poitevin aliénor
écrit à henri plantagenêt qu'elle est
libre de se remarier
séduite par le prince qu'elle avait
rencontré lors de l'hommage rendu à
louis 7 à l'été en 151 aliénor considère
henry qui est un héritier présomptif du
trône d'angleterre comme le seul parti
digne d'elle bien conscients des
avantages politiques et stratégiques
d'une telle union
henry ne tarde pas à se manifester il
épouse aliénor à poitiers le 18 mai 1152
à eux deux ils forment déjà un empire et
henry n'a pas encore fait valoir les
droits de sa mère au trône d'angleterre
ce sera chose faite en 1154
pour comprendre comment le nouvel ippon
davier nord henri ii plantagenêt accède
au trône d'angleterre
il faut remonter à son
arrière-grand-père guillaume le
conquérant
ce dernier duc de normandie conquiert
l'angleterre en 1066 dans une formidable
épopée raconté dans la tapisserie de
bayeux 1066 c'est guillaume le duc de
normandie guillaume le bâtard qui
réussit la conquête de l'angleterre et
qui se fait couronner roi d'angleterre à
westminster le 25 décembre 2000 66 alors
pourquoi est ce que c'est important
parce que les héritiers de guillaume
vont s'associer au fameux plantagenet et
il va s'en suivre des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années de guerre de
succession d'angleterre de province
française etc etc
le fils de guillaume le conquérant henry
premier beauclair accède à son tour au
trône d'angleterre mais en 1120 son
héritier meurt dans le naufrage de la
blanche nef lors d'une traversée de la
manche
henri premier beauclair désigne alors
comme héritière sa fille mathilde
surnommé l'empereur s car elle est
mariée à l'empereur henry 5 du
saint-empire la petite-fille de lieux le
conquérant mathilde mathilde l'en presse
avait épousé comme on le sait l'empereur
germanique henry 5 puis il meurt elle va
épousé en deuxièmes noces geoffroy
d'anjou et elle va avoir avec ce son
deuxième mari un fils qui sera henri
henri ii plantagenêt à la mort du roi
d'angleterre henry premier beauclair en
1135 son neveu etienne de blois formant
un coup d'état
il se saisit du trésor royal de
winchester se proclame roi d'angleterre
et se fait couronner grâce au soutien de
l'archevêque de cantorbéry c'est le
début d'une véritable guerre civile qui
va enflammer l'angleterre pendant près
de 20 ans un combat acharné va être
menée en angleterre entre mathilde et
son cousin etienne de blois c'est
mathilde qui finira par prendre
l'aventage et accédera au trône
d'angleterre le fils de mathilde et
geoffroy henri plantagenêt
le célèbre henri ii plantagenêt
en 1154 à la mort détiennent de ploie
conformément au traité de wallingford
signé l'année précédente
henri plantagenêt devient roi
d'angleterre sous le nom d'henri 2 il
est couronné en l'abbaye de westminster
le 19 décembre 1154 avec aliénor
d'aquitaine rennes pour la seconde fois
henry 2 va devenir le fondateur d'une
dynastie légendaire et édifier un
véritable empire qui va fragiliser le
pouvoir du cap et sia le précieux
héritage d'aliénor en plein coeur du
territoire français devient possession
du roi d'angleterre
l'apport de cette dot par aliénor
d'aquitaine sera très important car à l
aile inversera le rapport de force entre
les deux souverains d'abord à la faveur
de luis est roi de france puis à la
faveur d'henri ii plantagenêt roi
d'angleterre le territoire qui
appartient au plantagenêt à cette époque
et est assez remarquable
il hérite par son père geoffroy 5 lebel
de la touraine de l'anjou et du maine
par sa mère mathilde et bien de la
bretagne et de la normandie par sa femme
aliénor d'aquitaine
alors là de la guyane en la l'aquitaine
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui de l'auvergne
de la gascogne du poitou également et
puis au final de l'angleterre dès son
couronnement
ce mariage stratégique d'aliénor et
henri ii est un véritable coup politique
ils font de lempire officieux des
plantagenêts aliénor apporte un immense
territoire qu'elle avait déjà apporté au
roi de france louis 7
mais surtout c'est une enclave anglaise
au sein même du royaume de france
un état dans l'état alors évidemment ça
va poser des problèmes car sur ses
terres françaises
henry 2 même si les rois d'angleterre
reste le vassal du roi de france henri
ii c'est un homme d'état un meneur ses
colères sont d'ailleurs célèbre et il a
la volonté forcenée de devenir
l'alexandre de l'occident les stigmates
de la guerre civile sont encore très
présent en angleterre
le roi donc besoin d'une personne de
confiance pour diriger les affaires
pendant son absence
en france il doit faire valoir ses
droits et affirmer son pouvoir face aux
velléités d'indépendance de ces barons
et la puissance du capétiens louis seth
henry 2 laisse donc naturellement les
rênes du gouvernement anglais à aliénor
alors qu'il mène une expédition
militaire vers toulouse pour faire
valoir les droits de son épouse comme
l'a fait louis s'est avant lui jean de
salisbury leurs contemporains et
secrétaire de l'infortuné thomass
beckett rapporte le caractère
interchangeable des deux souverains dans
les débuts du règne henry 2 a toute
confiance en son épouse
c'est une tête politique elle a déjà
prouvé sa valeur en aquitaine puis sur
le trône de france en montrant de réels
talents de gouvernance l'autorité de la
reine est bien réelle elle prend la tête
de la chancellerie elle édicte
d'ailleurs plusieurs charte royale sous
sa signature sans que le roi ne valide
ses décisions elle assure ainsi d'une
main de fer
une véritable régence elles arbitrent
les conflits gère aussi les finances sur
le run d'aliénor la vie de cour renaît
dans le sillage de son illustre aïeul
guillaume le troubadour elle fait du
mécénat artistique une priorité et
exalte la grandeur royal la souveraine
ébloui ses convives par de somptueux
banquets où se croisent les plus grands
poètes et musiciens du temps qui
chantent
l'idéal de l'amour courtois celui ci
prône un amour fondée sur un libre choix
réciproque qui ne peut se faire qu'en
dehors du mariage car on ne peut aimer
ce qu'on possède
le statut de la femme évolue elle n'est
plus considéré comme un objet sexuel
dont on dispose
ou avant entre destinée à perpétuer la
race elle est désormais libre d'aimer et
doit être séduite selon un code précis
malgré les pressions de l'église
cet amour devient au 12e siècle une
valeur louer et chantée par les poètes
même si cet idéal littéraire ne se
concrétise pas vraiment dans la société
aristocratique
on a beaucoup parlé des cours d'amour
rassemblant les plus grands poètes du
temps au tour d'aliénor ou de sa fille
marie de champagne
ces cours qui prescrivent les règles de
l'amour courtois et dictent la conduite
des amants appartiennent sans doute un
peu à la fiction
quelle est la part de réalité évidemment
ces cours sont sans doute de pure
invention
c'est vrai qu'aliénor a joué un rôle de
mécène important d'ailleurs plusieurs
oeuvres littéraires lui sont dédiés le
troubadour bernard de ventadour
s'adresse à la reine des normands dans
l'une de ses chansons
henri deux droits nomades issu d'une
guerre civile parvient à ériger un
empire où il travaille à imposer son
autorité à développer une administration
solide et à instaurer une justice
centralisée lorsqu'un les de plantagenet
est arrivé à chinon il a trouvé une
vieille forteresse qui avait été
construite par les comptes de blois et
ensuite amendé par ses ancêtres les
comptes en joue la transformation
importante qu'il a effectuée à la
forteresse de chillon c'est la
construction d'un palais 9 plus commode
pour loger son administration et qui se
trouvait sur le fort saint georges en
1163 henry de rentrer en angleterre et
reprend la quasi totalité de l'exercice
du pouvoir
aliénor tête politique ce sont les et de
voir ainsi réduite ses prérogatives mais
elle travaille à fonder une dynastie
légendaire après avoir donné trois fils
et trois filles en pleine santé à henri
2-1 dernier fils jean voit le jour en
les fils d'ali nord grandissent la reine
est bientôt délaissé par henry qui
préfère la compagnie de sa maîtresse
la belle rose monde le roi fait de
londres la capitale de son royaume où il
s'emploie à centraliser le pouvoir
il tient soigneusement ses fils à
l'écart des affaires ce qui mécontente
aliénor
depuis son avènement henry 2 s'appuie
sur son fidèle chancelier thomass
beckett premier officier de la couronne
il est responsable des actes et des
chartes émises par le souverain
supervise les clercs maillon de
l'échiquier sa cour administrative
fiscale et judiciaire et accompagne
aussi le roi dans ses campagnes
militaires en 11 162 henry d'eux commet
une faute stratégique en faisant nommer
thomas becket son fidèle chancelier
archevêque de canterbury
il se retrouve donc à la tête de
l'église d'angleterre
par le biais de thomas becket henry deux
pans soumettre l'église d'angleterre à
son autorité et se passer de la vie du
pape
mais c'était un mauvais calcul parce que
beckett va se poser en adversaire du
pouvoir royal et en défenseur acharné de
l'église sa mission est désormais
d'affirmer le pouvoir spirituel du pape
en angleterre
henri de temps alors d'étendre son
autorité sur l'église via les
constitutions de clarens dont en 164 et
la situation s'envenime
beckett est accusé de malversations
il s'exile fait jouer ses relations avec
le pape
et bientôt des menaces d'excommunication
pèsent sur henry 2 finalement le roy
préfère négocier en décembre 11 170
beckett rentrer à canterbury
mais là il est assassiné dans sa
cathédrale
le 29 décembre 11 170 par quatre hommes
proches d'henri deux alliés nord est
horrifié le pape
j'ai alors l'interdît sur le royaume
d'angleterre
2168 à 1173 aliénor renoue avec sa terre
natale
henri ii lui a confié une mission de la
plus haute importance
il a le plus grand mal à maintenir ses
barons du poitou dans l'obéissance
ces derniers voient d'un mauvais oeil
l'autorité de ce roi anglais sur leur
fief
henry 2 compte donc sur la légitimité et
les talents d'aliénor pour faire
accepter son autorité elle gouverne
d'aquitaine en toute liberté
formulant quelques rêves d'autonomie qui
sortent vite à la politique
centralisatrice d'henri 2 ce dernier n'a
pas donné de fief à ses fils qui sent
pourtant en âge de gouverner et commence
à montrer leur impatience
henry 2 place tous ses espoirs dans son
fils aîné henri le jeune en 1170 il le
désigne clairement comme son successeur
en le faisant couronné est sacré roi
d'angleterre
mais le père conserve le pouvoir aliénor
elles voient tant son cadet richard sont
dignes héritiers appartement où les
enfants sont devenus des adultes
responsables et bien que son mari l'une
court un peu le guide ou de droite et de
gauche
eh bien elle va prendre une position
pour les enfants et elle réclamera des
portions d'héritage a donné soit à
geoffroy soit à richard lebeau petit
dernier plus tard jean sans terre lui
comme son nom l'indiqué restera très
longtemps sans héritage en 1173 après
avoir obtenu l'alliance de son premier
époux le capétiens louis 7
aliénor et ses fils déclenché une
insurrection contre henry 2 qui se
propage dans tout son empire
c'est vraiment une querelle de famille
jeudi soir là c'est une querelle de
famille une querelle d'héritage la
riposte d'henri ii et foudroyante
il repousse les français il mate la
rébellion étant des kills choisi de
pardonner à ses fils il emprisonne
aliénor l une en aquitaine avait soutenu
la révolte de ses fils contre leur père
et lorsqu'elle a cherché à s'enfuir à
fuir son mari henri ii plantagenêt
elle a été rattrapée par lui et il l'a
fait emprisonner à la forteresse de
chillon pendant plusieurs mois à partir
du mois de novembre 11 173
elle y restera jusqu'à son départ en
angleterre au mois de juillet 11 174
donc elle repart en angleterre avec son
mari henri ii plantagenêt et après sa
captivité de quelques mois à chillon
elle restera enfermé en angleterre selon
la volonté de son mari dans la tour de
salisbury pendant près de 15 ans la
pacification de l'aquitaine est menée
par richard lui même qui est pourtant à
l'origine du soulèvement le fils préféré
d'aliénor reaganien surnom coeur de lion
une prophétie fait par merlin cinq
siècles auparavant inquiète pourtant
henry 2 elle évoque la libération d'un
aigle à deux têtes par sa troisième
niche et placé en résidence surveillée
aliénor disparaît du paysage politique
pendant plus de 15 ans
entre 1164 et 1185 est écrite une série
d'ouvragés qui est considéré comme la
genèse de la littérature française
l'auteur originaire de troyes s'appelle
chrétien il est le protégé de la
comtesse de champagne marie fille aînée
d'aliénor et de louis 7
son oeuvre s'articule essentiellement
autour de la légende d'arthur et des
chevaliers de la table ronde que
chrétien va participer à transformer en
mythe l'influencent de l'amour courtois
en remontant vers le nord rencontre le
modèle du roi chevalier et chrétiens
invente le roman de chevalerie
imprégné par les aventures d'arthur et
de ses chevaliers les plantes à genève
ont influencé les romans des siècles à
venir
tout comme les capétiens se réclame
descendants de charlemagne les
plantagenêts se disent prolonger la
ligne et d'arthur chevalier aussi et
mérite que lancelot du lac
richard punissez baron rebelles avec la
même brutalité pour fédérer le capétiens
lui peut s'appuyer sur le sacre mais
encore faut-il avoir un héritier après
la mort de sa seconde épouse en mettant
au monde sa quatrième fille
we7 se remarie avec adèle de champagne
après la naissance d'une fille une
seconde grossesse sur louis vote alors
en rêve le fils tant attendu il tient un
calice rempli de sens qu'il donne à
boire aux grands du royaume
le miracle a bien lieu louis 7 a enfin
un fils le 21 août 1165 qu'il prénomme
philippe halley le champagne est une
femme fréquemment malades assez malingre
et il n'arrive pas à avoir un héritier
avec elle il est désespéré jusqu'au bout
de 30 ans de vie commune
on n'a toujours pas vu son épouse
portait un fruit or ce fruit se profile
à l'horizon
philippe de auguste est sacré en 1179
jour de la toussaint la pérennité de la
dynastie capétienne assuré we7 peut
mourir en paix le 18 septembre 1180
c'est maintenant philippe qui jouent des
dissensions entre les quatre frères
plantagenêt et leur père dès sa première
entrevue avec le nouveau roi de france
le vieux plantagenêt est impressionné
par sa prudence et son assurance qualité
que doit avoir un roi chevalier mais
qu'il ne retrouve pas chez ses fils
l'héritier du trône d'angleterre henry
le jeune succombant 1183 après la mort
brutale de geoffroy en 1186 richard
coeur de lion n'a plus qu'un frère
le prince jean henry 2 désigne richard
comme son héritier en angleterre il fait
de gens son successeur en aquitaine la
guerre devient fratricide
richard ne comptant pas faire une croix
sur l'héritage d'aliénor cette discorde
inquiète le plantagenet à paris philippe
auguste est résolu à ramener ses vassaux
dans le rang aliénor est alors utilisée
par henry 2 pour calmer les ardeurs de
ses fils en 1187 une terrible nouvelle
arrive d'orient le sultan d'égypte
saladin s'est emparé de jérusalem alors
que tous ces héros chevalier font voeu
de croisade à l'exception du prince jean
pendant les préparatifs les combats
reprennent et la prophétie de merlin
s'accomplit philippe auguste se
rapproche de richard et affronte avec
lui le vieux roi henry 2 pour qui c'est
la dernière bataille
le roi philippe auguste va l'aider dans
sa lutte contre son père les aigles
favoriser l'accession donc au pouvoir
parce que philippe auguste et richard
était très lié très amis à l'origine ce
fameux traité d'azay-le-rideau et un
traité qui a précédé de quelques jours
la mort du roi henri ii plantagenêt
ils étaient pourchassés par le roi de
france et par ses fils notamment richard
coeur de lion qu'on dit que ce traité
d'azay-le-rideau et une pelleteuse pour
henri ii plantagenêt
par ce traité il prend connaissance
aussi
de la trahison de son dernier fils jean
sans terre et il va reconnaître par ce
traité un certain nombre de territoires
au roi de france ainsi que le mariage de
son fils richard coeur de lion avec la
soeur du roi de france
ainis vaincu envie de se soumet pour la
première fois de son existence
apprenant que même jean a participé à le
trahir
il meurt sol le 6 juillet 1989
henri ii plantagenêt fini ces derniers
jours abandonnée de sa famille et de ses
enfants
donc il vient jusqu'à chinon où il va
passer ces derniers jours et où il
mourra seule et abandonnée de tous
richard coeur de lion est couronné roi
d'angleterre
ali n'aurait libre et en tant que reine
mère elle fait son grand retour à la
tête du royaume
elle n'a rien perdu de son acuité
politique et se hâtent d'envoyer des
représentants recueillir les serments de
fidélité au nouveau roi en 1990 avant de
partir en croisade
richard lui koffi naturellement la
régence du royaume
les deux roi richard coeur de lion et
philippe auguste partent ensemble pour
la troisième croisade le 4 juillet 1190
avant de prendre deux routes différentes
qui les font se retrouver en sicile en
septembre où ils attendent le printemps
brichart dit philippe auguste ce serait
bien que vous m'accompagner en réalité
il se méfie de philippe auguste il se
dit si je pars en croisade seul il va il
va risquer de récupérer mais territoire
le même l'anjou et la norme anti donc
ils partent en croisade et il arrive en
sicile où ils sont accueillis d'ailleurs
par des normands puisque la sicile est
un royaume normand fondé autrefois par
robert de l'iss car tancrède de
hauteville et là il tombe malade
quasiment en même temps l'un et l'autre
on souffre de ce qu'on appelle la suède
millière ils perdent leurs cheveux ils
perdent leurs ongles on perd le fil par
un oeil même philippe auguste vers hanoï
et ensuite direction la terre sainte
si richard a mobilisé toutes les
ressources possibles pour faire de cette
croisade un succès couronné d'exploit de
chevalerie philippe est préoccupé parce
qu'il laisse derrière lui un royaume où
son autorité s'est renforcé et un fils
louis orphelin de mère à trois ans les
prouesses de richard aux combats l'ont
précédée en sicile et on attend de lui
qu'il règle un problème de succession
alors que philippe est partisan de la
négociation afin de stabiliser la
situation
richard en fait un problème personnel
qu'il faut régler avec panache il décide
de ramener l'ordre à sa manière en
mettant à sac messine mais surtout en
plantant sur les murailles de la ville
ces étendards la fierté du roi de france
et particulièrement éprouvées tandis que
philippe traverse directement la
méditerranée pour rejoindre saint jean
d'âcre richard passe par chypre îles
dépendantes de l' empire byzantin mais
dont le prince à la recherche
d'autonomie collabore avec salade à
l'occasion est belle pour richard
d'ajouter une ligne à la liste de ses
exploits
chypre est conquise il peut maintenant
rejoindre saint jean d'âcre ou philippe
peine à prendre la vie
avec richard à villeton les deux
bannières flotte cette fois-ci ensemble
le duc d'autriche veut aussi planté son
étendard richard lui refuse ce droit et
traîne sa bannière dans la boue très
rapidement on va voir que la mésentente
vint s'installer sur la terre sainte
entre richard et entre son ami philippe
auguste une amitié dont il faut se
méfier parce que philippe auguste lui
veut absolument combattre saladin gagner
saint jean d'âcre et richard arrive en
retard enfin on sent que sylla et
conquérant l'autre est hésitant et
philippe auguste va dire bon dans ces
conditions ça suffit je rentre la
prochaine étape est jérusalem philippe
malades préoccupé par les affaires de
son royaume décide de rentrer en france
dès 1991 il s'arrête à rome pour obtenir
du pape l'absolution en disant voilà je
quitte la croisade ne m'en veuillez pas
et pendant ce temps là richard lui va
rester ce se battre parfois même comme
comme un soudard parce qu'on sait qu'ils
massacrent à tour de bras
il attend on lui a promis la vraie
couronne du christ et comme il ne
l'obtient pas eh bien il massacre des
prisonniers
la reconquête de jérusalem est
hypothétique et de toute façon la gloire
on reviendrait à richard devons
jérusalem sans les troupes de philippe
auguste et charles coeur de lion doit
composer avec salade à la ville sainte
restent aux mains des musulmans les
chrétiens pourront s'y rendre en
pèlerinage
richard refuse de rentrer dans jérusalem
en pèlerin puisque ils rêvaient de le
faire l'épée à la main en octobre 1192
il prend la mer une tempête l'obligent à
changer d'itinéraire
il doit traverser le duché d'autriche où
le duc ne l'a pas oublié malgré son
déguisement et chara capturés et vendus
à l'empereur germanique henry 6 que
philippe auguste a eu tout loisir de
rangées de son côté
le roi de france complotent alors avec
le prince jean qui s'autoproclame roi
d'angleterre
mais jean ne peut atteindre son royaume
car lille est défendu par les barons
fidèles à richard sette aliénor qui
veille
bouleversé par la capture de son fils
préféré aller nord écrite au pape pour
lui signifier son indignation en signant
ses lettres aliénor par la colère de
dieu reine d'angleterre
elle parvient à rassembler une rançon
astronomique de 100000 marque soit près
de 20 tonnes d'argent ce qui représente
leur venue du royaume d'angleterre pour
deux années echard libéré
j'en demande immédiatement pardon et
fait massacrer la garde française
protégeant evreux en signe de repentance
sitôt débarqué en angleterre où il est
accueilli par les acclamations de la
foule qui chantent et dansent richard
puni des partisans de son ambitieux
frères aliénor quitte l'arène politique
dans laquelle elle s'est battue comme
une lionne et se retire à l'abbaye de
fontevraud pensons pouvoir se consacrer
pleinement à sa vie spirituelle
quand il est libéré enfin grâce à la
rançon versée par aliénor d'aquitaine et
bien richard naturellement et
immédiatement constate que le
comportement
quel a été le comportement de son frère
jean sans terre john blake landes comme
on l'appelait à londres on voit tout ça
dont les fameux roman de quentin durward
robin des bois bien s'aperçoit que il la
faille il usurpe et la couronne donc
évidemment et fall puni rival
emprisonnés mais il lui pardonnera très
rapidement
les affaires rappelle richard en france
il quitte son angleterre
il ne reverra jamais le premier
affrontement entre richard coeur de lion
et philippe auguste a lieu en 1194 à
fréteval entre la normandie et l'anjou
et voit la déroute de l'armée française
la perte du trésor royal ainsi que de
nombreux documents indispensables à
l'organisation du royaume de france
après fréteval richard coeur de lion
inflige encore une sévère défaite aux
français à issoudun en 1995 et l'année
suivante il signe une paix précaire avec
philippe auguste le traité de gaillon
fini peau buste qui entend bien casser
cet empire officieux des plantagenêts
pour asseoir son autorité sur ses fiefs
en france et afin de protéger la
normandie
richard érige alors en vallée de seine
un château qu'il veut imprenable château
gaillard
[Musique]
alors philippe auguste n'a qu'une idée
en tête c'est récupérer la normandie
donc il va lancer quelques attaques sur
la frontière de de l'ile-de-france et de
la normandie
richard bien sûr voulant conserver ce
duché qui est quasiment une annexe de
l'angleterre va couvrir la frontière va
ceinture et la frontière de
fortifications que ce soit à verneuil à
ivry que ce soit à gisors et surtout et
surtout la clé de voûte de ses
fortifications c'est le fameux château
gaillard d ang lee qui l'a construit en
un an de temps ce château a jailli de la
falaise en un an de temps le constatant
cette réalisation d'ailleurs eu il aura
cette expression merveilleuse qu'elle
est belle ma fille d'un an quel château
gaillard
comme leurs noms l'indiquent les
forteresses et les châteaux sont des
lieux fortifiée il était donc surtout
destiné à protéger et à maîtriser un
territoire
il y avait cette notion de maillage du
territoire ponctuée par par les châteaux
pour commander les territoires et on le
voit bien à chinon avec ce site de
hauteur qui est placé sur un éperon
rocheux qui lui permet de surveiller les
alentours et d'avoir une position
privilégiée
l'esprit chevaleresque de richard coeur
de lion le pousse à défier la mort
pendant les combats alors qu'il enchaîne
les victoires en normandie le destin le
rappelle une dernière fois en aquitaine
où le vicomte de limoges est passé du
côté français brichart surveille toutes
ses possessions et notamment on lui
apprend que en limousin dans la ville de
chalut deviennent aujourd'hui est bien
un de ces de ses suzerains aurait
découvert un trésor est naturellement ce
trésor lui revient
richard le lui fait savoir et le
suzerain lui ne veut pas du tout s'en
séparer s'en débarrasser alors ils
servent à les assiéger la ville de
saintes de chalut en limousin c'est à
l'occasion de ce siège qu'un tireur
d'arbalète puis décoche un carreau qu'il
reçoit les indices dans le dans l'euro
dans le dans les pôles les autres disent
dans le fondement mais georges est il
que l'infection se met dans la plaie
elle va mourir richard coeur de lion
sentant la mort arriver echard demande
sa mère à son chevet il expire dans ses
bras le 6 avril 1199 aliénor est une
vieille dame elle doit encore se battre
pour isséens plantagenêt sur le trône
d'angleterre
son acharnement est intacte sa
détermination sans faille il revient à
jean de ceindre la couronne
arthur de bretagne le petit-fils
d'aliénor prétend aussi à la succession
et passe la tacc dans le poitou aliénor
et victorieuse jean devient roi
d'angleterre et se déclare vassal de
philippe auguste à la paix semble enfin
revenu entre le cap et siens et le
plantagenêt trois ans plus tard aliénor
à 80 ans quand elle négocie les
fiançailles de sa petite fille
blanche-de-castille avec le fils de
philippe auguste le futur 8 de cette
alliance va naître saint louis une
impulsion inconsidérée de jean vient
tout bouleverser
ils enlèvent isabelle d'angoulême la
fiancée de l'un de ces faso en suzerain
avisé philippe auguste fait valoir le
droit féodal et n'a pas la bonté
d'attendre la disparition d'aliénor pour
faire du prince jean le seul fils qui
lui reste
le jean sans terre d'une histoire qui
conforte la légende
le conflit entre le cap et siens et le
plantagenet se poursuit à bouvines en
1214 la victoire du roi de france sera
sans équivoque
aliénor d'aquitaine c'est un au
printemps 1204 la grande reine repose
aux côtés d'henri 2 auprès de son fils
richard et de sa fille jeanne à l'abbaye
de fontevraud qu'elle a voulu nécropole
royale
2154 à 1204 la dynastie plantagenêt
règne sur un empire officieux qui
s'étend des îles britanniques aux
pyrénées et où londres s'affirme comme
capitale portée par des personnages
exceptionnels qui lui ont donné une
cohérence administratives et idéologique
cet empire voit naître les prémices de
la construction politique de
l'angleterre moderne deux dynasties
rival des capétiens et les plantagenêts
ont cherché à imposer leur hégémonie
dans un conflit sanglant que les
historiens considèrent comme la première
guerre de cent ans
un parfum de scandale embaument de son
vivant déjà le destin d'aliénor qui part
ça les gens de noir entrent dans les
livres d'histoire
huit cents ans nous séparent de sa mort
et le tend à gommer les contours de
cette reine fascinante et paradoxale qui
demeure une vibrante incarnation du 12e
siècle